all right it looks like uh we're now
live uh we're
starting just a couple minutes early
because I see there's already quite a
few questions for this AMA session
so I'm going to take this uh longish one
which has a lot of moving parts to it by
alionic
I study creative writing in English
literature at University and if you want
the truth lately I've started feeling
kind of insecure about the subjects I
study I feel that since I'm dedicating
my studies to something that doesn't
directly contribute anything tangible to
society like medicine engineering Etc
that I'm no good love my subjects but
lately can't shake this feeling did you
ever experience any similar thoughts
throughout your time studying philosophy
and as a matter of fact I did and I was
just talking with my friend Mark Schmidt
about this great
um what would you call it like remedy
this uh thing that one of my professors
told me when I was struggling with
similar thoughts but before I go into
that I want to say that you shouldn't
assume that studying medicine or
engineering or anything like that
automatically provides tangible benefits
to
um or contributes in any tangible way to
society I mean medicine you could say
that but most of our doctors here in the
United States spend more time filling
out paperwork than actually interacting
with patients some of them don't pay
attention to what their patients are
saying I've had doctor visits where I've
like gone in talk to the nurse the
doctor looks at you know the chart gets
things completely wrong I have to
correct them and they spend a total of
five minutes with you before you know
deciding what to do about things don't
make an assumption that people in other
fields are making greater contributions
or anything like that a lot of them are
you know sometimes actually screwing
things up you know so it's it's not as
if people who are studying business or
communication or any of the stem degrees
are automatically doing more than people
in the humanities and as a matter of
fact
sometimes uh and it's kind of random
when this happens you run into people
that are benefited by something you can
bring to mind I remember a colleague who
was very down because
um you know she was doing the right
thing and and her her fellow colleagues
were giving her a hard time and I
brought up something that I'd just been
reading from Saint ansem about virtue
and vice and you know vicious people are
going to tear down virtuous people and
it was just write the the thing for her
at the time that helped put things into
perspective so there's there's a
contingency involved in that so here is
the metaphor that my uh Professor Rick
Williams who may or may not still be
alive he was he was quite old when I
studied with him back in graduate school
gave to me because I came to him and I
had a similar thing with respect to
philosophy now he wasn't a philosophy
Professor he was a Classics Professor
but I I studied Plato's Symposium with
him in in the Greek over the course of a
semester
and I said you know it kind of feels
like all I'm doing is like learning
stuff that then I'm going to pass on to
a new generation of students and I don't
really know whether any of this is
genuinely valuable and what what the
hell's the point in in all of this
and he said well here's here's the way I
look at it and he'd actually gotten this
from his mentor years earlier so you can
say that on a meta level something
similar to what he was talking about was
uh was uh being expressed he said I'm
somebody who sits by a fire and that
fire was going long before I came on the
scene and there was somebody else
tending that fire sometimes there's more
people sometimes there's less and
there's people who come and warm
themselves by the fire and they're not
going to tend the fire but they find
something good something useful in that
fire for the time being
um my job is not to turn it into a
fancier fire or to pick it up and spread
it somewhere else my job is to sit here
by this fire and keep it going and
anything else that happens
is gravy anything else that happens is
nice but that's my main job you know to
keep my
faculties my skills my knowledge Base
active to think about this stuff to look
at it from different perspectives and to
continually Feed The Fire And if nobody
else comes along and decides to take my
place after I'm gone and the fire goes
out I did my job you know I did I did
good enough I what I did was of benefit
and if somebody else does come along and
wants to learn from me how to tend this
fire or to figure it out on their own
that's cool too
I I found that really helpful
um myself
and uh I've passed that on to other
people and they found it helpful as well
and you know so that it's sort of
attending fire about tending fire and I
think you can think of some of the
things I mean provided you're not doing
like
stuff that nobody is ever going to care
about other than a few faddish people
um you know if you're if you're working
on stuff that really does matter in the
humanities uh in literature you know we
talk about Classics and classic
literature I think that uh
you're okay and the crisis of meaning
you know of not contributing anything
it hit stem people too you know you can
be an engineer and do your job well and
wake up in the middle of the night
thinking what the hell good is anything
that I'm doing
you know you can be a doctor and you can
you can go into other fields and do that
as as well some fields are probably more
prone to those sorts of existential
crises than others uh because it's hard
to tell what they actually do but
so you know don't get too discouraged
about it it takes a little time to get
out of it
here's a one from somebody calling
themselves God which is you know pretty
hubristic I think how does Hegel know
that all forms of Consciousness collapse
and lead to Absolute knowledge couldn't
there be more that he hasn't thought of
yeah of course
I mean whoever told you that that Hegel
had everything right
I mean Hegel uh certainly wanted to
bring things to a close in the
phenomenology which is probably what
you're referencing right because
absolute knowledge did Hagel stop
writing books stop giving lectures stop
going into the other stuff
obviously not you know is everything
that's in the philosophy of right
already contained in the phenomenology
doesn't seem so to me you know Hegel
continued to to do things and
um
all forms of Consciousness don't
collapse and lead to Absolute knowledge
uh they're still out there sublation
doesn't mean that they cease existing as
a matter of fact only a very you know
select few get to participate in the
absolute knowing that that hegel's
talking about at the end of the
phenomenology so you might want to
give a rethink to what it is that Hegel
is actually saying and you know whether
Hegel could be partly right or partly
wrong you know he we don't have to
necessarily buy into uh the whole
hegelian you know set of claims that we
often call a system in order to find
some of the things interesting or useful
I mean obviously history hasn't ended in
1807 right so this is this is one of
those sort of pseudo problems I think
you could say that you don't necessarily
have to impose upon yourself
uh here's a good question from Galen
have you got a favorite speech from the
Symposium and also maybe a speech you
disagree with but I think we can take a
good lesson from nevertheless yeah I
mean I I don't really agree I mean
favorite and agree isn't those aren't
the same thing
um I don't actually buy deodima's speech
myself but I think we can certainly take
some good lessons from it
um I kind of like the Aristophanes
speech a lot because it's this crazy
story about
um
you know our Sexes and what we were
originally and finding the one who fits
for us and there's all these like you
could call them plot holes in the story
that Aristophanes is telling but he
doesn't care because he's a comedian
right and maybe Plato doesn't even care
because he's just depicting Aristophanes
in there I also really like paulsonius's
speech which is um I think kind of
underrated
he makes some interesting observations
about how the law Works in different
places and
you know how we should think about
um Love and Desire
um I I think that his speech ought to be
titled there ought to be a law you know
so those are probably my my favorite
uh James asked are you familiar with
pure Grimes in the noetic society if so
are they good resources I don't know if
they're good resources I can tell you
that when I was doing my philosophical
counseling training and certification he
got mentioned as somebody important you
know in the Socratic method but I've
I've never actually looked at his stuff
um I mean that's not necessarily A index
of quality or anything there's literally
thousands of philosophers whose stuff I
haven't looked at
um so I'm not I'm not really a great
person to to talk about it he seems you
know legit serious I don't know about
the noetic society
um and I you know I kind of think the
Socratic method
um good sometimes kind of overrated for
for some things it's not a uh a perfect
way of approaching everything but uh
yeah I mean that'd be one of those
things you want to check out for
yourself I probably won't get around to
it myself
Fabian says glad to see you today it's
been a while yeah good good to see you
here Dean how do you take notes when you
read philosophy do you mark in the
margins of the book rarely I don't take
many notes I've never really been a note
taker even back in
um you know K through 12 I I would kind
of if it's important to me I usually
remember it sometimes I'll make little
you know if I want to go back to
something I'll make a little indication
occasionally I underline but then
sometimes I come back and find that I
underline the wrong things you know so
I'm not I'm not a good person to give
advice about how to take notes um
there's there's lots of people out there
who are much more into that than I am
um and I'm kind of an outlier when it
comes to that so what works for me
probably doesn't work for everybody else
um Jamie Styles what is the best fiction
book on nihilism you've ever read I've
never read a fiction book on nihilism
um if you're asking me instead what is
the best fiction book and I'm going to
extend this to series rather than book
uh that involves nihilism or raises it
as an issue that I've ever read
I mean offhand I would say
um
well there's two two answers to that
one would be Ursula Kayla greens the
farthest Shore
which is part of the
the uh Earthsea Trilogy which then
becomes a series of six books and I
would add to that
um the fourth book as well
um uh which is in which the main
character is is uh tenor and you know I
would even include
um the the second book as well
um the tombs of artoan because what
you're dealing with is the questions of
meaning death power what to do how to
deal with conflicts and all of that sort
of stuff
um in the farthest Shore a mage who is
terrified of dying has found a way to
break down the wall or break down the
the division between
um the the dry lands where the dead are
and
um
the land of the living of Earthsea and
so you know some really interesting
speculations in there on Ursa Kayla
Green's part and then something a bit
more contemporary I would say
um our Scott backers
uh second Apocalypse series which is a
you know seven books at this point in
time
um it's set against a universe which is
not you know it's not a nihilistic set
of books but they are certainly
struggling with questions of meaning and
whether there is any ultimate meaning
within the universe how we should behave
how we should struggle against evil
should we you know just develop into
sort of like seeking power and Hedonism
or something else
um you know those are some really long
books though Scott our Scott backer you
know is was also a philosophy graduate
student and you can say that in place of
writing his dissertation he brought out
his first book you know has probably
done more to promote thinking than most
people's dissertations have so you know
those would be some good ones
um lap says how do you understand
Heidegger's notion of the temporal
Horizon he describes it in places as a
dateable content of nowhere then seems
to reflect the focus on intentionality
uh so a lot of moving pieces there I
mean let's begin in a straightforward
way we exist in time right we exist in
temporality as well and this imposes
Horizons and what is a horizon well this
is an idea that Heidegger is getting
from hussarel so everything has Horizons
the fact that you can't see the back of
my head right now means that there's a
kind of horizon there and this is a
spatial thing you supply you know me
being a three-dimensional object even
though you're seeing me on a screen and
we're constantly projecting all sorts of
things ahead of us
into the world that we're perceiving and
that's part of temporality for Heidegger
that's the pre-understanding orientation
towards the future we also have mood or
Attunement uh which is you know sort of
anchoring us in a past that is coming
forward into the present right we have
thrown-ness this is the four equip
memorials right and then we have
language and sometimes Heidegger plays
around with other stuff as well
um and you know that's sort of like the
big big picture stuff and being in time
um but you could also think of like all
different ways in which we make sense
out of or project time into things like
you know right now we're 15 minutes into
this AMA how do I know because I can see
it like ticking away up there and we're
projecting oh we're going to be here for
another uh hour and roughly 15 minutes
although sometimes I go over right and
so these are all you know sort of
everyday examples of of that
um Leander has another uh
um Heidegger question how did Martin
Heidegger's philosophy influencium
um you know
a variety of ways I don't know that his
influence uh very often is a matter of
just Heidegger influencing me the
Heidegger is part of like a number of
people talking about similar things that
I'm interested in so you know as a sort
of phenomenologist looking at The Human
Condition
uh I would say that what Heidegger has
to say for me gets you know kind of put
together also with what Gabrielle Marcel
or Maurice Blondell or you know honorean
bergson or mock Shaler all of his
contemporaries right have to say about
things
and said why don't I say like what I
think is cool about Heidegger's
philosophy so there's a point that he
makes
in
um what is metaphysics that I think is
really you know quite good which is that
um
you know whenever you start looking at
one genuinely metaphysical question and
you start pulling at the threads of it
you find that it's connected to other
ones
I think he's completely right about that
it you know you can't just work on this
problem by itself in strict isolation
from everything else like you're some
sort of weird robot type the way that
some philosophers want to do
um they all bleed over into each other
and so metaphysics is going to be messy
so is ethics by the way right I mean
this is one place where I don't agree
with Heidegger and I do agree more with
like mock Shaler you know Gabriel Marcel
ethics is just as important as
metaphysics it's not like doing ethics
puts blinders on and gets us you know
automatically off the track and we start
you know restricting being I really like
Heidegger's treatment of mood you know
and emotions I think that that is
incredibly helpful and valuable uh but
he's building off of previous thinkers I
mean he brings up Aristotle you know and
says Aristotle's uh rhetoric book two is
the first hermeneutic of you know I
think he says herb America
he's talking about the like the stuff on
the emotions right this is in being in
time as well
um I do like the uh discussion of how
human Freedom introduces something new
into existence and it does so precisely
by
moving out into the nothing I think
that's actually you know
people make fun of Heidegger for for
that but I think those are people who
don't really understand what Heidegger
is is trying to get at
um what else I mean I I enjoy reading
Heidegger's uh discussions of previous
philosophers I don't always think he's
you know completely right about it but I
do think that he's quite insightful
um so you know those are some examples
um Marco says is it important for a
philosophical study of Aristotle to know
if his surviving texts are what he
actually wrote or if the texts were
distorted over the centuries by copying
and editing
um for almost 99.9 of us that's a side
issue that's of very little relevance I
mean how the hell would you know right
you're going to have to trust some
experts somewhere and it's not like
we're back in the Renaissance with some
you know Dusty manuscripts in front of
us like which which of these are genuine
you know I mean we've got like 200 years
plus of people who've devoted you know
their lives and careers to putting
together
um critical editions of things so I
think most people who quibble about that
sort of stuff are just wasting their
time rather than using it for something
valuable like actually reading the texts
and figuring out what they what they
mean right
um so no it's not really that important
anymore uh particularly for for
Aristotle you know anything where we've
got critical additions I think unless
you're going to become a textual scholar
you do like I do and you you say okay
these are what we're going to work with
thank you for for for putting together
these critical editions so I think
that's kind of a um a non-starter you
know uh Andy what do you think of
concept albums
if you enjoy them do you have a favorite
concept album
that's a good question I mean
I think it's tough to pull off a concept
album
and here I'm going to say some broader
stuff about music and and sort of like
programmatic ideas in general I'm also
going to fix this light a little bit
there we go
um
a little blind there that's nice
so you know the first concept album that
I ever heard was Pink Floyd's The Wall
right and that was a big deal for us as
as kids you know uh we we could relate
to a lot of it not not only because you
know teachers kind of sucked back then
education wasn't great but you know or
you could think about the the fears
involved in like the song mother and you
know of course we weren't like well some
of the kids were doing drugs they're
mostly sniffing glue but I didn't I
didn't get into that you know so there
was you know you could talk about the
drug use and being burnt out and then of
course you get older you get into high
school and college and Pink Floyd The
Wall is really cool back then I mean now
I see it as kind of uh not not very
interesting to me and then the next big
concept album that I think I paid
attention to was Queen's reich's
operation mind crime right
um
and that was pretty cool too I mean
great songs uh there's an interesting
coherent narrative by that time there
were videos going along with it
um
but I think there's limitations to
concept albums
you know
you can talk you can like talk about
sing about play about cool things but
there's a sort of superficiality to most
concept albums I think right
um
because there's only so much you can
actually do
and it winds up being kind of slogony
and
um I don't know not you know it can be
they can be good gateways into thinking
about things but
I don't know that most concept albums
really measure up over time you know
other than just being about the thing
that they're about they're not like a
blueprint for for how to live our lives
um
and you know I'm going to talk about a
different thing
um we went and saw Rage Against the
Machine this uh summer at Alpine Valley
and I was you know I was really struck I
mean there were there were two things I
was really struck by and and my wife was
also struck by one of them
um there was Zero interaction between
the band and the audience which I guess
is kind of common for them but to me why
do a live performance if you're not
actually going to engage with the
audience I mean we may as well just
listen to the record right
so that was a weird thing but it's also
reflective of something else you know
while Rage Against the Machine was doing
their you know wiki wiki you know uh
guitar stuff that you know who is so so
you know so amazing uh I I actually find
that stuff really boring and while the
Stinger was you know ranting about this
and that and you know going into all
this sort of like hard left resistance
stuff and they're they're playing these
images on the background
I was reflecting on it I was like wow
this stuff is really superficial I mean
and put aside the hypocrisy of like how
rich the band members are and how they
don't engage with their audience anymore
and just think about the words itself
they're cool
but they're not a political program
they're not a substitute for actual
thinking Praxis as a matter of fact they
can be a great distraction from that and
if you looked out at the crowd it was
run the jewels and Rage Against the
Machine and who are the most of the
people in the crowd were they people who
are like yeah I'm going to transform
Society man and resist the forces of uh
Fascism and you know uh capitalism and
commercialism and all that no they're
just a bunch of drunk you know 40 year
olds who remember hearing this stuff
when they were younger and maybe
actually cared about stuff uh hooting
and hollering and going around and
acting like anybody else at a concert
right
so I I coming back to uh concept albums
I mean think about like um Queen's Reich
was engaging in a very interesting
social critique in operation mindcrime
did it really mean anything no not
really unfortunately you know so
you know you could say I'm not I'm not
super into to uh um concept albums
all right
um zeeshan what's your take on zoophilia
and minor attracted persons is it
morally okay in your opinion definitely
not morally okay in action and I would
say that if you've got you know
attractions like that you probably want
to uh do some reflection about uh is
this something appropriate I was just
actually talking with somebody I mean we
don't even have to go to like extreme
stuff like that I was talking with
somebody just the other day about
um there are these skeevy professors who
are like my age and they hit on
um college students who are generally
you know 18 to 24 year old and I was
thinking you know I was saying
if you're 50 years old and you're still
finding yourself uh primarily attracted
to people that young
there's some some maturation that hasn't
happened in your in your development and
you should look at yourself and wonder
what's going on and instead of like you
know appealing to like evolutionary
psychology other pseudosciences you
should actually like look at yourself
and say how did I get so screwed up you
know that I can't be attracted to
somebody my own age you know
um I think there's you know there's
something to that and that's probably
enough to say about about those sorts of
things
all right
um Tina says love this off the cuff
style of discourse even better than your
lectures very comfy and natural
um I'll take your word for that about
the comfy part
um I think that's one of those younger
generation words that I may not know the
full extent of but it sounds good
uh Jim I take your book organization as
a personal upfront I'm not sure how you
could possibly see what my book
organization is
um from this you can't see the titles uh
except of maybe a few of them that have
really big words on them but you know if
you want to take something as a personal
upfront well
life is short so you know
if you think about that maximum uh uh I
was invited to write an article in a
magazine I'm a scholar in criminal law I
want to write something about criminal
law in connection with philosophy do you
have any suggestions
Google would be very helpful I'm sure
that if you enter criminal law
philosophy there will be like hundreds
of entries that come up and they could
furnish you with all sorts of idea
um I don't I don't know that you know
any of them would be more germane to you
or your studies because I don't know you
you know so I don't know what what you
should write on
uh Zach says no I haven't chatted in a
while but hope you're doing well thanks
I hope that you're doing well as well
um David Reynolds has a completely out
of context question here doesn't he say
you should believe in God even if there
is no God I don't know who the he is
there so uh that sounds like a factual
question that could be easily answered
by reading somebody's book
uh rulento how can I decide when I'm
prepared to start reading the next
philosopher I want to going from Plato
to Aristotle with philosophy it's hard
to realize if I've understood enough so
that one actually I can't answer
um you've understood enough when you're
ready to read something else I mean that
sounds tautologist but hey it's your
brain you know you right you should be
able to figure out whether you've made
enough progress and it's not like once
you've read Plato you can never ever
ever go back to him I mean you will go
back to him because you're going to
forget half the stuff that you think
that you you know learned
um within you know a little while and
you know you you move on to other
philosophers like Aristotle is going to
say some stuff about Plato and then
you're gonna be like is that what Plato
actually said let me go back to the
Plato text right so there isn't a
formula for this
um I would say that what you want to do
or what you could do I mean I don't know
what you want
um what I would suggest doing is not
worrying about whether you've learned
enough
and uh when you're you know you feel
like you could go into Aristotle to
start reading Aristotle this doesn't
have to be like a a very formulaic you
know systematic or I have to do this
first and this prerequisite
it's your brain you can read whatever
the hell you want you don't even have to
like necessarily read Aristotle you
could go right from Plato if you want to
to Rene Descartes and then come back
again there there isn't any
um
I mean people present it as if oh you
got to do this first and then this first
and then this first or else it's no good
most people are full of crap they don't
know what they're talking about
um there's there's many many ways to
study philosophy so you know when you
when you uh want to start reading
Aristotle just start reading Aristotle
and you don't even have to stop reading
Plato you can have two books open at the
same time you know
all right Dan the Man uh uh long time
subscriber and and commenter and his
comment just jumped because so many
people are are weighing in and it
updated let me see if I can find this
again here we go was there ever a point
where you felt Jaded by philosophy just
graduated from my masters a few weeks
ago and I haven't wanted to think about
philosophy at all lately yes there there
have been times and they often do
coincide with exactly the sort of thing
that you're talking about where you've
been like investing all this time and
thought and energy and maybe even like
worry and communication into a
philosophical project so if you just
finished your Masters you finished up
with your coursework you defended your
Master's thesis you know those are those
are that's a lot of work right
and you put a lot of time and energy
into it
um and then you know you get done and
it's even more so like after you finish
your dissertation some people get
depressed after that uh other people are
like I don't want to think about this
dissertation topic for another couple
years let me just read something else
you know
I mean I kind of did that with my
dissertation which was kind of a hot
mess now that I think about it you know
um
I mean it it's kind of fortunate I
didn't try to publish it because that
would have been a lot of frustration
because it really should be like split
into a couple different books
we can hear the rain that's
we got a
crazy rain storms going on here in
Milwaukee uh with like gale force winds
out on the lake and you know
we're probably gonna have some flooding
and stuff like that anyway back to the
topic yeah it's totally natural to have
times where you're like yeah I don't
feel like doing philosophy you know I do
a good bit of my reading actually in the
in the tub because I like taking hot
baths you know from my joints and stuff
like that and you know like uh not not
quite at the level of Churchill who
would conduct all of his business in the
bath but like you know Aleister McIntyre
who told us when he we were in the
seminar that he he enjoyed reading in
the bath sometimes I'll bring books
and I'm like yeah I'm gonna read this
this Cicero you know on the ends so I
can talk about it and instead I just
read some uh some stories you know or I
just like fall asleep in the tub or
something like that right I mean there's
you can't I mean you can force yourself
to read stuff but you can only do that
so long and you've probably been doing
that quite a lot while you were
um preparing for your your Masters right
so
um
maybe take a couple weeks and just like
chill out and do other stuff for a while
you know
uh ridicule the private vices yield
public virtues or just general thoughts
on that idea no
um I think most of the pr for private
vices yield public virtues tends to be
BS and very selective I mean that's a
slogan but slogans shouldn't be a
substitute for actual thinking private
vices tend to lead to public vices and
screwed up situations and Injustice and
exploitation and all that sort of stuff
I mean think about greed right does
greed really create public virtues no
does it even create public benefits well
kind of but usually with the
externalities placed on somebody else's
shoulders who we're not even seeing so I
would avoid that kind of slogan
[Music]
um
all right let's see here
Ariel do you have any horror books or
movies to recommend
um yeah I mean I do
um so let's think about books
you know I'm still a fan of Lovecraft as
racist as he is I mean he he even
doesn't like you know Portuguese and
French Canadians
um and he's pretty pretty awful when it
comes to that but he is also a master at
um
riding a horror stuff
um
I I did Bram Stoker's Dracula a couple
years ago in the world's a speculative
fiction and uh also the lair of the
white worm and I kind of like that stuff
I think I would like to go back to it
eventually
um who else in horror I mean there's all
this great stuff out there at this time
that is done in the lovecraftian
universe and I mean I I actually like
find these books these anthologies on
Kindle and you know nobody like
automatically comes to mind as like the
great author but you can easily search
that somebody who I'm a big fan of
um you know you can think about horror
fantasy and there's two authors
who I particularly like when it comes to
that
um both of which unfortunately are are
long past one of which is Carl Edward
Wagner with his Cane stuff and uh tanith
lee who's incredibly prolific and and
she wrote across
sci-fi fantasy horror you know she's
she's really I I really like her quite a
lot
um and as far as like movies so you know
it was just Halloween and we didn't
actually make the time to watch any
horror movies because we were you know
coming down off of stoicon and all that
sort of business but
um one of the scariest movies for me and
when I watched it it still held up I
watched it like about 10 years ago
Prince of Darkness
um that is a creepy creepy movie you
know especially towards the end so
there's a lot of other great ones out
there we live in kind of a wonderful
time when it comes to streaming content
right there's more than you could
possibly ever watch
um Jacob says don't have a question yet
but wanted to say hello and thanks for
what you do
great yeah that's you don't always have
to have a question
um
Zeitgeist for someone living in
Wisconsin have you ever listened to
Midwest emo I didn't even know there was
such a thing as Midwest emo but I
suppose it makes sense that there is
um I'm not into emo stuff so you know
um I probably haven't heard any of it
um unless I've walked through a place
where somebody was was playing it from
time to time or something something like
that I think it is kind of cool that
there is such a thing as Midwest emo
yeah I wonder if there's anything like
Midwest metal you know
maybe Midwestern themed you know
um laps have you tried ever tried
listening to Black Metal I find it to be
a thoughtful genre yeah I mean I
listened to Venom when when Venom was
you know brand new uh sort of the
Godfather's a black metal
I got bored with much of the stuff that
was coming out later because it often is
very technically proficient but I just I
don't get into it I'm not into black
metal I'm not into death metal I'm not
into you know Viking metal there's a lot
of like genres that I don't have to be
into cool that you are but you know I
got other stuff I like listening to you
know
um all right let's see what else we've
got here
um
let's see Mario are you worried about
the future of the United States
I am not worried about the future but I
am pessimistic about the future
and
I'm not worried about it because I you
know I look at things in a bigger
perspective
um I'm an American just like Augustine
was and boethius were Romans and the
Roman Empire is uh long gone and was
falling apart when they were around
um but
you know the stuff that they did was
still valuable and you know I'm not
saying that I'm like an Augustine or
boethius that my my stuff is going to be
around 200 500 a thousand years you know
plus from now but
um
if the United States goes away that
doesn't mean it's like Humanity
disappears or something as a matter of
fact uh the American experiment I would
say has um been effectively derailed you
know if you read like classical American
literature you see that at least a lot
of the people in America despite you
know doing terrible things they at least
had this concept like we better not
screw this up
you know think about like John Winthrop
and and the city on a hill you know uh
sermon
um he's like listen uh we've got a
unique opportunity here let's not screw
it up think about Alexis to tocqueville
this French Observer of what's unique to
American democracy that's almost all
gone that's long long gone you know and
even the uh conservatives are like in
love with state power you know and
coercion and stuff like that
um and you know I think that our
political system is in effect uh stuck
in gridlock in some places sliding into
fascism in other places
um there's been a breakdown of um
political and social mores as I talked
about in in a you know uh live stream
about probably a year ago
um we're sort of a paper tiger when it
comes to a lot of you know economic
educational matters we spend way too
much money on a military that is not
giving us uh the dividends that we need
and we piss it away on you know upper
rank people who are just part of an
elite that that get to run things and on
equipment uh and we we do terrible
caretaking of our veterans after they
they get out you know that's not where
the the money is we've got two political
parties one of which is mostly
well-intentioned but often seems to be
like three steps behind their opponents
and one that over the last uh 20 to you
know 15 years has degenerated into
crazy lovers of Cruelty fascism you know
owning the libs and all all this this
sort of stuff and we have you know media
environment that that promotes all of
this kind of crap so I'm not very
optimistic about this this country or
what's going to happen
um that said you know
um
you know I grew up here I'm going to
stay here and uh do what I can to uh
help improve things in little ways you
know
so
all right
um minji where is evil Sadler bring him
back you fiend he comes out kind of
randomly whenever he wants to you know
very often topically oriented
um I'm sure you'll see him before too
long
um
yeah like Zeitgeist points out you'll
see other comes out when he wants to is
an uncontrollable entity and let me say
too my advice is you shouldn't listen to
anything that evil Sadler says because
he's full of crap
um by camera monk are you familiar with
do you have any opinions on the
recapitulation theory of atonement no
that's that's not a term that I'm I'm
familiar with
um I'm sure it's you know popular in
some some group or something
um Mario
what do you think Plato would have
written about in today's world about a
perfect state within the possibilities
of a decentralized blockchain technology
I think that Plato would have taken one
look at that and been like holy crap a
new cave
you know for people who uh think that
they're out of the cave so that's
probably enough to say about that uh
again if you could have majored in
anything else other than philosophy what
would it be
well that's an interesting question
because I did major in something else
besides philosophy I double majored in
philosophy and Mathematics
and if I hadn't been so tired of being
in college I actually had the
opportunity to triple Major
because interestingly enough our history
of philosophy classes of which I took
let's see ancient and medieval modern
contemporary I took three that would
have counted towards a history major at
the the college that I was going to and
I also had taken a couple other history
classes just for fun and then there was
like a world Civ one in world Civ 2. so
I think I had like on the books like
I want to say like seven classes if I
would have continued on and I only
needed like 10 classes to
um triple Major but I I just didn't feel
like hanging around for another semester
so so I Didn't Do It
um
I mean it was kind of random that I got
into philosophy anyway I've talked about
this at many points
um I could actually I considered
changing my my major to writing and I I
think I've I've certainly told this
story elsewhere but I may as well tell
it again very briefly so Carl Elder was
a right it was a writing an English
professor at Lakeland College and I
would sit in on the Poetry classes that
he taught in Parks I was going out with
uh a girl who was a writing and um art
major
and so I would hang out with them and
I'd you know bring in my poetry and an
elder was very uh critical of
everybody's stuff and
um I I respected his opinion and I
thought you know I want to be a writer I
still want to be a writer today
actually and uh I went into his office
and I was like I'm thinking about you
know switching from philosophy to to
English and and you know writing and he
said oh that's a terrible idea you know
don't do that you know and I said well
why why shouldn't I do that he said all
these these friggin kids come in my
class and they're all like basically
doing these meta projects where they're
writing about being writers and you got
to actually have something to write
about and so if you study philosophy you
could do writing but you got something
that you could think about it write
about you're reading some other stuff
not all these pretentious English people
you know uh you'll be so much better off
doing doing that and I was like oh
that's that actually makes sense and so
I didn't change my
um
I didn't change my major so yeah
um
Ken never ceases to amuse me that
there's a traditional metal Revival
genre it must be said it features some
great bands though nice to see
traditional metal surviving and thriving
yeah I mean I think there's
so Ken by the way is is a long-standing
uh uh commenter and has been part of the
classic metal classes that Scott turilli
and I were doing before our schedules
um got in the way and we're hoping to
take that up again so I think you can
say that there's really three
intersecting let's call them traditional
heavy metal things so there's heavy
metal from the time before it was
traditional heavy metal because it was
just heavy metal the 1970s and and the
1980s right and some of these bands
um got their start in the 1970s you know
like think about uh of course Black
Sabbath and and deep purple and Uriah
Heap and then you know
um Judas Priest and you know Motorhead
and Van Halen and you know rat and and
you know of course there's kiss in the
background Iron Maiden forms in the 70s
but doesn't release their first album
until the until 1980 and so you got all
these different bands that are doing all
this cool stuff right and
um where exactly the boundaries of metal
and hard rock or prog rock are that's
difficult to say so I'm not going to get
into those weeds so we got that stuff
right now you think about like Twisted
Sister as an example too you know they
they are classic or traditional heavy
metal sort of like go ahead punch
through stuff they played a lot in clubs
before releasing their first album I
want to say in like 81 Maybe
um
so anyway you got that right so that
that's one kind
and then we have the continuation of
those bands into the present so like you
know I'm gonna go and see wasp
um and Armored Saints uh next week
and wasp is going to do you know
probably mostly like the stuff from the
the 80s but there'll be like some new
newer songs from the 90s and early 2000s
in there as well uh you know we saw
Michael schecker group um just the other
day and they they played a lot of old
cut UFO stuff
um actually about close to half the
concert was UFO stuff from the 70s and
then it was Michael schechner group
stuff and you know some of it was things
that I could easily identify armed and
ready you know cry for the Nations these
standards but then there was stuff like
off of very recent albums which I have
to I'm a little shame to admit I've only
listened to once or twice and
um so that that's also traditional heavy
metal right so now we got two kinds
the original stuff from the original era
continuation of these bands into the
present and then we've got like a whole
wave of bands from the 2000s onward who
are like I want to play this old kind of
stuff you know and uh yeah some of what
they do is pretty cool there's there's
other bands that are it's hard to say
where they fit in with it like
uh like Primal Fear for example right
um
very very Judas Priestly sounding in the
way that like Orchid is is very uh black
sabbathy sounding
um
and you know maybe they kind of straddle
the classic era and the Contemporary era
as well so yeah
all right
um
Wim says who do you like the most out of
these three and why to lose Lacon or
darita
for me that's no contest I I like Lecom
better than the other two I mean I enjoy
reading to lose less so when he's uh
working with Qatari more so when he's
doing his own thing I enjoy reading some
darita when he's not farting around with
all sorts of word games and wasting our
time with that kind of [ __ ] which
half the time that he's making a point
he is doing
laca is also subject to a little bit of
preciousness you know writing in obscure
ways and there's some false starts I
would say you know whenever Lacoste
starts talking about mathematical
formulas just tone that out because
that's that's you know that kind of
stuff seems kind of ridiculous to me but
laca as Aleister McIntyre pointed out
um was working within a tradition even
though he's very anti-traditional he's
working within a tradition of
psychotherapy that ultimately can't be
just about like theorizing it has to be
about like helping people figure out how
screwed up they are and helping them to
get a little bit less unscrewed up so
they can live a better life right
um so and I enjoyed lacon's writings
more than I do these other two
um
Ariel says do you have any living
philosophers you like I have many of
them some of them are my uh
colleagues you know
some of them are people with big star
power who I've met
um I mentioned Aleister McIntyre living
philosopher the real deal when it comes
to Virtue ethics
um cool guy uh I had the chance to you
know interact with him years back for
for a while and um I try not to place
any like you know uh especially since
you know he's so old I don't I don't
want to like take up his time with
trying to bother him about stuff because
he's got plenty of people doing that
um Juliana's I got to meet her at
stoicon uh years back that was you know
like getting to go behind it was like
getting to be backstage at a uh Rock
concert with your favorite people
Anthony long similar sort of stuff we'd
have these dinners after the stoicons uh
or or sometimes before where we get to
like hang out and chat and stuff
um Christopher Gill of course uh really
wonderful guy
um you know there's there we're talking
about people who are like Emeritus
status
um but there's yeah there's plenty of
contemporary people who I uh I like as
well you know some of whom I've got to
meet and interact with largely through
you know either the institute for Saint
Anselm studies or
um the modern stoicism organization or
the Aristotelian studies thing so yeah
there's lots of lots of contemporary
thinkers who I like
um
C says enjoy tolstoyed just finish some
of his short stories I have to say
master and man and the death of even
illich were Sensational yeah tolstoy's
pretty good you know he's also got some
he's got an interesting book that I
teach sometimes parts of to my uh
students at Milwaukee Institute of Art
and Design what is art so I enjoy him
raid are there any books analyzing
fascism you would recommend yeah there's
actually a whole bunch I I've actually
written an encyclopedia article years
back you can find in my academia.edu I
think where I've got like a bibliography
of the stuff there have been new things
since then like I think Paxton's book on
fascism came out after that
um you know Aaron's Nolte sometimes gets
gets dinged a lot
um but I think his three faces of
fascism is is still pretty good and it's
it's nice because it brings in the
integral nationalism and Alias uh not
Alias process axio France says uh as
being a proto-fascist organization
um
I want to say Paxton's book is varieties
of fascism
um but there's there's a number of good
works out there that that you know you
can find from like the 1980s onward that
explore it you want to avoid the ones
where they've clearly got an ax to grind
you know or where it's kind of weird
crap like uh
um what was his name Jonas something's
liberal fascism which was right about
some things but wrong about others
um so yeah all right uh Cody do you
prefer teaching Hegel or Kant and why
either one's fine I don't have a
preference
um I'm not a hegelian or a conscient but
they both are interesting I'd say
hegel's tougher to teach in part because
everything's so interconnected but yeah
um
RT Whitby did Aristotle think virtue was
a means to the end of eudaimonid or do
you think that virtue was valuable in
its in and of itself or both obviously
both right this is something that
there's a whole ream of scholarship out
there on and a lot of people waste time
with this I think it's super clear in
the text that you know if happiness
consists in eudaimonia the life of
active virtue well then it's not just a
means and thing it is inclusive
and the more virtuous you are provided
you also have friends and and you know
enough wealth to keep a roof over your
head uh the happier you're going to be
um I don't know why there's a lot of
like tiffs that people get into about
air so is Aristotle's view on friendship
altruistic or egoistic
neither those aren't categories that are
that are really applicable there people
get themselves I think very often in
these these kind of artificial binds
that they don't they don't need to
um
all right uh let's see here
um oops just skipped a little bit
um let's try to take some people we
haven't had already
um
Austin says I'm in a intro to philosophy
class I want your opinion on the Dr
Seuss Horton Hears a Who to Plato's
allegory that seems silly I'm not going
to bother with that so uh
I mean the allegory of the cave Horton
Hears a Who I guess they're both about
like hearing you know seeing something
somebody else doesn't but why do those
two uh what does it have to do with
being in an intro class uh piffle um who
do you find to be the most interesting
philosophers of the last 20 years
I mean there's interesting and then
there's interesting for me and
interesting for me is going to be a very
much smaller
um
category because I'm not reading most of
the philosophers who have written in the
last 20 years as a matter of fact people
are often like what do you think of
so-and-so and I'm like I've never heard
of so and so you know and that's kind of
normal
um
last 20 years okay so we're making the
cutoff
uh 2002
um am I reading a lot of stuff from that
I mean
so you know some of the people I've
already mentioned like Aleister McIntyre
Julia Annis uh Margaret Graver has some
some great stuff as well in ancient
philosophy obviously Christopher Gill
um
you know people doing like contemporary
Continental I don't really pay that much
attention to most of them you know in
part because I don't find what they're
doing all that interesting or or helpful
so I don't I don't I don't know I
probably have to pass on that right
um
so let's see kolamus
um what do you think about RG
Collingwood I got a hold of his
autobiography in Boston I quite like it
calling what's an interesting thinker
um
by the way you know I've mentioned
McIntyre a couple times guess who wrote
uh on Collingwood McIntyre and he liked
Collingwood quite a bit
um you know the things that I've read
and I can't say that I've read much or
that it's been very recent I've I've
enjoyed
um so he's he's worth checking out
uh Rexel kuised POG any insights on
January John Henry Newman's philosophy
uh it's been like decades since I've
read him so I don't have any insights in
particular about his philosophy
um
uh nature says we turned art for this
moment when we know something we feel it
but we can't articulate it because it's
too complex a multiple great quote human
all to human oh okay well there there
you go uh said I struggle with
understanding some of the philosophical
texts such as those of German idealism
phenomenology and existentialism I was
curious if you could offer some solution
to this problem the problem of
struggling to understand things I don't
have any thing that can contribute to
that other than saying uh understanding
is something that you develop
cumulatively it's not it's not an on off
switch it's something you have to work
at
um
we all struggle understanding some
things you know it's not like when I'm
shooting the half hour Hegel videos I
just like read the passage and I'm like
oops there it is let's get up there and
shoot you know I have to re-read it and
think about what's there and what I want
to say
um that's kind of par for the course so
um you know it gets better I think over
time but you don't have to like place a
burden on yourself that you have to
understand everything there's going to
be some people who you just can't make
heads or tails of and it could be
because what they have to say isn't all
that coherent or it could be because
um you yourself aren't ready for
studying them at that time you know
you're jumping you know like all these
people who are like oh I got to study
critique of pure reason it's so
important
how do you know it's so important you're
trusting somebody else who said that it
was so important who might
you know have as little understanding of
the text as you do you know I mean if I
had to pick a text that like is the
Hallmark for philosophy it sure [ __ ]
wouldn't be uh cons critique of pure
reason and if I was going to recommend
studying one of kant's critiques and
getting something out of it I'd probably
recommend the second critique the
critique of practical reason you know
um but people get very
you know invested in this idea that they
if they're not understanding something
they're they're really missing out on it
you know
um so
just you know kind of keep um
keep uh working at it I would say
Ethan Bishop what would Plato think
about 2022 Republicans in the midterms
in America and Plato would hate their
guts
um because they're pretty despicable
Republicans you know I've I've actually
done a registered Republican at one time
and I've I've been involved in
Republican races the Republican party of
today is almost
unidentifiable in relation to the
Republican party of say 1985.
there are so many positions on which
they've reversed their their Viewpoint
or they've like torn apart the Legacy
um Plato would say well these are just
you know these are basically corrupted
degenerate people who want to believe
things that clearly aren't true and
they're motivated by malice spite Envy
you know they've really made a mess of
themselves and they are a big feedback
loop making a mess of themselves you
know he wouldn't necessarily say that
the Democratic party is is great people
either but
um it's not night and day it's sort of
like darkest night and
um Twilight you know you can still see
in one of them you know
um so that I think that's probably what
Plato would say
um
Andre says I I love I read a lot maybe
it's I a lot of mountains on education
of children oh a lot of uh montanes uh
educational children thoughts resonated
with me what would you read next on
philosophy of education whatever the
hell you want to I mean it's not as if
you have to read everything in a perfect
chronological order you know I I guess
if you want to read modern philosophy on
education you could read Rousseau's a
meal or you could read Locke's thoughts
on the education of children or you
could read Mary woolstone crafts
um uh Vindication of the rights of women
which is uh arising it's written
specifically to a minister of Education
during the French Revolution or you
could go backwards in time and you know
read you know Plato uh and you know the
Republic has all sorts of interesting
things on education or whatever you want
to it's up to you you know I I don't
have like a syllabus of what you have to
to do
um
all right online person does hegel's
negative portion of dialectic and the
phenomenology of spirit rely on a
certain type of alienation and is this
related to Heidegger's nothingness no
and no
um I wouldn't I wouldn't try to like
theorize in those ways
um that's sort of like the big you know
top-down kind of stuff that people take
if you're going to read the
phenomenology of spirit just read the
phenomenology of spirit don't don't
approach it with a whole bunch of
preconceived ideas because Hegel tells
you not to do that in the very preface
right
um so I wouldn't I wouldn't do that and
is it related to Heidegger's nothingness
read Heidegger on Hegel you know yeah
he's got a whole whole book on the you
know lectures on the Phenom the uh
phenomenology of spirit which
unfortunately only goes up to the
self-consciousness phase see if
Heidegger talks a lot about the nothing
there right uh
he doesn't so William Zen will reading
all of Frederick
oh you must be uh Cobblestone right
Frederick cobblestone's history of
philosophy books be enough to get a good
grasp of the history of philosophy do
you think we can get a good enough
background to read philosophy well I
think it sure as hell can't hurt right
Cobblestone is pretty reliable obviously
Cobblestone died a while back so there's
there's some things that have happened
since then
um
and uh
you know should you should you be
relying primarily on somebody's history
of philosophy or should you be reading
the primary texts themselves you know
um Cobblestone is not trying to provide
you with a substitute for actually
engaging with the texts themselves he's
trying to provide you with a Fairly
reliable guide and I I think he's pretty
good usually but certainly better than
Bertrand Russell I would say he's
actually probably better than Grayling
who's a contemporary person who
um you know wrote a history of
philosophy recently
um but there's going to be gaps there's
going to be things that are left out
that that Cobblestone just as much as
Grayling are not very aware of you're
not going to find a lot of women
philosophers who deserve to be looked at
uh in either of their histories of
philosophy or Russell's or yeah I would
say too
um
if you're going to read somebody read
cobbleston definitely do not waste your
time with William Durant's the story of
uh philosophy because that is so often
off base about things you know and very
selective so
all right Ethan Bishop what would
Aristotle think about the Electoral
College
I mean he would call that part of the
what what he calls a constitution I know
that here in America we're used to
thinking of the Constitution as like a
written document but for Aristotle
Constitution palatea means like the
arrangements within a society
and I think if he were to look at it
today he would be like well this is
clearly a institution that has outlived
its usefulness it leads to all sorts of
um bad uh
um
incentives a lot of corruption I mean I
think and this would just be one thing
where Aristotle would be like wow this
nation has really got itself in a bind I
mean he would be like we need to get all
these lobbyists out of here
um all this money that's being spent on
electoral campaigns this ought to go
um you know unlike other countries where
you're not allowed to campaign for you
know months or years on end America does
that he would say that's terrible as
well you know what a waste of resources
um it leads to social conflict of All
Sorts
um Aristotle would probably look at
American governance and be like this is
this is some messed up stuff you know
um
see a video maybe on The Parables found
in the New Testament does that sound
like something I would do a video about
I mean if I generally when I do a topic
do I do a video on a complex topic or do
I do a whole series of videos and so you
know I could do something on the
parables in the New Testament
um does that sound like something that I
typically do do I do a lot of stuff in
religious studies or do I focus mostly
on philosophical texts
um and if you want to see that sort of
thing you know if you want a commission
videos you know that we could do that
but I've got a lot of philosophical
content to do first
uh War but do you think the big
questions have been answered by
available philosophy to theories need to
start being created through an
engineering lens I can't you know I can
think of worse things to do than
creating through an engineering lens but
with the engineers and Engineering
professors that I know
um
it would be pretty bad
um Engineers quite often are good at one
thing and pretty awful at a lot of other
things including higher level thinking
so hell no
I mean if I had to pick a profession
that I wanted to like turn philosophy
over it sure [ __ ] wouldn't be engineers
I think I'd rather turn it over to
Medical people and that would be a
catastrophe too or to lawyers and that
would be a catastrophe too or to
Communications professors and that would
be a semi-catastrophe because at least
they study some Humanities based things
um and you know
have the big questions been answered
sure the big questions have been
answered there's like a whole bunch of
answers out there you got to figure out
which ones you actually think are right
is have they been answered in the sense
of like there's definitive consensus on
the the answers to the big questions
hell no and there never has been and
anybody who tries to tell you that there
is
way off you know so yeah I I you know we
should we also shouldn't like turn
things over to the mathematicians or the
computer science people or the
economists
um I mean Plato already had Socrates
talk about that in the apology right
Crafts People Technic you know technetes
who know one thing quite well they have
knowledge about that and then they think
that they know about all sorts of other
stuff as well you know
um
all right uh
Ethan Bishop do you have your red
philosophy drunk yeah sure I mean it's
not recommended you're probably gonna
miss things but uh I drank plenty back
in in undergraduate and graduate school
and sometimes I'd come home and read
some philosophy but I didn't get that
much out of it
um it's harder to follow complex things
I had more Read Literature or or stuff
like that you know
um
and uh let's see what else we got
um
barless what are your thoughts on
William Blake as a philosopher don't
really have any because I haven't
studied Blake much so
um endless nameless what are some good
theories of knowledge for dealing with
the gettier problem I don't know I'm not
an epistemologist and I don't do
analytic stuff which is where the
gettier problem basically belongs
uh MDG do you find anything coercive in
modern Progressive politics if so what
yeah there's plenty of stuff that could
be coercive I mean for a long time I was
much more of a Critic of the left than I
was of the right I'm kind of uh you know
choose who the biggest biggest uh
bad people enemies uh threat are kind of
person and so you know you could say
that from
probably the 90s into the the like
mid-2000s I was much more critical of of
the left than I was of the right
I think sometimes you know identity
politics and by the way there's just as
much identity Politics on the part of
the right you know
um can be kind of you know Silly and
divisive and I think there's a lot of
people who might be well intentioned but
they get they get their hands on some
Theory and then they like start applying
it in very crude ways that often happens
you know I I mean I run into things
um where where people will on the left
will be like you know you teaching
philosophy is just you know Europe that
European white guys and I'll be like
well
Plato wasn't white to begin with because
that wasn't a category back then he was
Greek and he thought that we were all
barbarians basically yeah
um so these categories are not that that
applicable and but you know they don't
make it jump through hoops is it as
coercive as what's happening on the
right these days and then not by far I
mean there are some places that people
complain about oh what about Evergreen
College that's an outlier go to the
average college and indoctrination isn't
really taking place the way that the the
right Wingers want to claim
um that's that's just logical and
opportunistic and trying to get people
riled up against them college-educated
smart people you know
um so yeah there's there's there can be
coercive stuff and maybe there could be
new coercive stuff in the future you
know
um all oppose those who I see as being
the greatest enemies of virtue and
freedom at any given time and right now
I see the the real threats coming from
the right
all right Northern Bohemian realist on
Tuesday I get to see Fran Leibowitz and
Madison who I think is Socrates for our
time comment
I don't know I mean what does it mean to
be Socrates for our time wandering
around and asking questions being a
gadfly Socrates is kind of an [ __ ]
you know in a lot of the cases why would
you want to be Socrates that's kind of a
heavy mantle to try to wear
um
you know
um I don't know enough about Fran
leebowitz to say anything so
um
Mark says uh I hope you're all well late
for tonight's session if we took the
pleasurable life seriously as an option
for the you diamonistic life what do you
think that would look like how would you
live a virtuous but pleasurable life
well I mean we have some discussions of
this in ancient philosophy right
um
the epicureans would probably be the
best candidates for them and
Cicero I would say in some respects
gives us the um
most coherent presentation of that he's
not an Epicurean but he's got an
Epicurean friend turquadus
who and on the ends book one gets to
present the the Epicurean life as one in
which we would you know develop the
virtues instrumentally
we would also have friendships which
epicurus thought was quite important and
and you know we would come to value our
friends happiness and pleasure
um
you know I I think that
we ought to pay attention to Pleasure
and Pain not as being like the be-all
and end-all but as being important I'm I
could say you know when it comes to like
let's say we got the hedonists of like
an aristoc
aristipian kind cyreneic kind
um or an Epicurean kind or just like
straight out hedonists or even like
later on you know the utilitarians we
got them on one side right and then
we've got
um
well we got a couple sides because we do
have like some Aesthetics who are like
anti-pleasure they think that pleasure
is bad some of the cynics were like that
um you kind of get that impression from
some moralists in in the early modern
and late modern period let's put them
aside because they're probably wrong
um but then you've got like say the
stoics right or Emmanuel Kant or people
like that who think that it's really not
there's no moral value to Pleasure and
Pain and then you got like you know the
Aristotelian platonic tradition which
says pleasure is a good it's just not
that good and
you know it should be an index of of um
virtue advice if you're if you're doing
virtuous actions but you don't actually
get pleasure out of it or you see other
people doing virtuous actions and you
don't get pleasure out of it there's
something wrong you're not fully
developed and I'm I'm you know more
Aristotelian and so you know I think we
should pay attention to what we find
pleasurable and think about it and make
that part of our philosophy
um we should try to seek things that go
just beyond mere pleasure but
um it's good to have pleasure some some
pleasure and and pain is
something bad just not the bad you know
so yeah
all right
um
lapse nine Continuum do you suppose the
notion of choosing or affirming one's
own suffering
purely for its own sake might be a kind
of contradiction or logical
impossibility
I don't know why you would choose or
affirm your own suffering just for its
own sake so maybe I don't think it's a
logical impossibility people do all
sorts of goofy stuff and that shows that
it's not logically impossible but why
the hell would you want to I I think if
you dug into it you would inevitably
find some for the sake of that's
different than the surface level for the
I'm doing this just for its own sake you
find like I'm torturing myself because I
feel guilty or you know I want to show
how tough I am or thing things like that
lurking in the background right so
um
Faison this is an interesting one what
your views on catch
I don't know that I actually have any
views on kitsch
I mean that's a term that's been used in
Aesthetics for a very long time
um
I'm not big on like cluttery Kitsch like
when you you know like if you ever go
into
some of these chain restaurants and they
get all this crap hung up on the wall I
guess you could say a lot of that's
Kitsch and it's supposed to you know I
kind of think of it it's there to
um cover up holes in the wall and to
give people who don't have much to say
objects to start conversation with each
other look at those license plates over
there you know
um
but Kitsch for its own sake isn't isn't
isn't really valuable you know I guess
we could say is it taking up the space
of things that uh otherwise would be
better to have
um Kyle do you have a favorite
philosopher I do not have a favorite
philosopher any more than I have a
favorite band
um I would say there's people who I
value more highly than others and enjoy
reading more than others but I don't I
don't have a favorite
I've gone through phases where I was
like totally into somebody
um but I left those phases behind you
know so
I don't I don't really have favorites
um
Ethan do you think Joe Biden should run
for re-election
I mean that's a good question ideally I
would I would rather see somebody else
um as the Democratic candidate I mean he
wasn't he wasn't my favorite candidate
although I I did vote for him in this
last election because I sure [ __ ] didn't
want Trump back in
um
I mean the the part of the problem is we
just you know the the phrase that Trump
had they're not sending their best
people we don't get the best people
from either side you know I mean the
Republican side was a complete [ __ ] show
that generated Trump and and it's still
I mean you look at the people that
they're that are thinking about running
holy crap you know
um all of them are are pretty pretty
dismal
um but you know can you think of
somebody on the Democrat side who could
feasibly step in and take Biden's Place
probably not and you know
maybe it's fine to have him in there as
the candidate he's pretty resilient you
know
um it's good at at saying funny stuff
off the cuff so you know
all right Ryan what do you think about
fukiyama's hegelian take on identity
politics I don't know if fukiama's take
on identity politics if he said
something recently it's not something
I've paid attention to I mean I wouldn't
call fukuyama all that hegelian anyway
he's more kojevian uh than hegeli and I
don't think fukiyama reads much Hegel on
his own at least that's my impression
Andre uh do you have any advice on
picking Role Models uh yeah I guess uh
what I would say is um
don't don't put them on too high of a
pedestal you know because they are human
and if you if you get too invested in a
person as being like your shining star
that's guiding everything sooner or
later they're going to let you down uh
and that's that's less on I mean that is
on them but that's also on you for for
doing that
I can't read Cyrillic letters so I don't
know how to pronounce this person's name
but what have you read from Nikolai bear
jayev what are your thoughts on his
Christian philosophy
um
I mean I read his Dostoevsky book years
and years back don't remember much from
it
um I don't have I don't really have
anything to say about bear jayev so
uh laps I suspect you could always
uncover ulterior motives as well I have
a hard time making sense of that idea
this must be a reference back to
something else
oh the choosing one's own suffering
right yeah so all right
um
barless thoughts on Thomas Merton's
approach to Eastern philosophies it's
been more than 20 years since I've read
Thomas Merton so I don't really remember
uh Mario what do you think about Jordan
Peterson's interpretation of the Bible
especially Exodus I'm sure it's garbage
because Peterson is mostly garbage uh
the stuff that he occasionally gets
right you can find in better authors so
you know
Bradley why do you think there's a gulf
between political theory and practice uh
why is wisdom and virtue removed from
the discourse why aren't political
philosophers taking a stand against the
buffoonery political philosophers are
taking a stand against the buffoon or
you can just you know they have been for
for generations and centuries why is
there a gulf between political theory
and practice by practice what do you
mean like the way things are done
um I mean again
common theme going all the way back to
Beyond Plato going back to Solon you
know you read his lyric poetry about
Injustice and stuff like that
um politics is is messy people you know
sometimes are motivated by good reasons
and sometimes just by greed or by stupid
ideologies that they've bought into or
the chance to screw over their neighbor
or pick you know pick whatever you want
I mean
um do you think it's it's likely that
we're going to see a complete
coincidence between some political
Theory and actual practice
um I I have rarely seen that
um another uh thing with Cyrillic
writing what do you think of philosophy
the philosophy of loving us
uh who is cooler loving us or Henry I'm
guessing Michelle laundry
um I mean I don't think of leving us or
Andre as being cool because I
don't think very often about
philosophers as being cool loving us is
okay
um he's doing some interesting stuff my
my mentor Garth Gillen was actually an
early translator of lavinas with his
mentor Alfonso Lingus before eventually
he pulled out of the translation thing
so I got fed a kind of heavy dose of
loving us Leven osians often tend in my
experience to be kind of uh whiny
down you know pessimistic people who are
like we're all you know we're all facing
the face of the other and theory is all
hypocrisy and you're like
so what do you suggest we do then buddy
you know and and I'm just kind of like
ignored most lebanosians I'm loving us
does have some interesting stuff on uh
um
uh interpretation of of scripture and
talmud that often gets overlooked
Michelle Henry is not somebody I've
actually spent any time on he was part
of this um
he was part of this big uh
like in France the French turned to
religion and phenomenology which which
is a real misnomer because it's not as
if the French ever quit in phenomenology
focusing on religion there's John
Herring there's you know Gabrielle
Marcel there's Paul recour there's all
these people who were doing that
all right say your thoughts on Zizek I'm
not very interested in Zizek
um his early Works where he's more
rigorous sort of like Dairy dye are very
interesting and insightful
I think at a certain point he just
started you know
thinking he could just like Spiel out
whatever he wanted and it takes so much
time to figure out what the hell he's
actually trying to say
um that I don't I don't find it
particularly valuable so
uh Andre just giving a thumbs up thanks
uh I'm bursting as hegel's phenomenology
compatible with his logic are there two
ways into the same conclusion
um I mean tell me what the conclusion is
if you want that answered because I sure
as hell don't know I wouldn't frame it
in terms of a conclusion and I don't
know what you mean by compatible I mean
you would think that they would be since
the same guy wrote them not too far
apart you mean the science of logic
right not the encyclopedia logic
um
I mean it's it's clear that one is not
even though they're intended that way
one is not really like the introduction
to the other
um they're doing very different things
they're both very difficult works very
complicated I wouldn't say that um it's
very I wouldn't say that it's
particularly useful to try to theorize
about their interconnection without
spending a lot of time with them and I
spend you know relatively little time
with the science of logic uh in the last
20 years or so compared to the
phenomenology so
all right
um
Mario asked another topic what's your
opinion on the new green deal climate
change and green growth I mean it's
evident that climate change is taking
place you just gotta like open your eyes
and pay attention and not like buy into
denial crap
um it was evident uh years ago I mean
you can see here in Wisconsin that the
winters are milder and we have species
uh moving North from Illinois into
Wisconsin and
um you know there's there's other things
that are taking place as well we're
lucky living here in the Great Lakes
region because climate change is not
going to mess us up the way it is other
places
a lot of the American South is going to
become uninhabitable you know within a
few decades
um and we're gonna have to figure out
what to do with all those refugees from
Red states in the South you know as they
come up here and uh you know
want to live their their
rather uh thoughtless lifestyle
up here the green New Deal I mean we
need something like it and
um
I mean this is one of those examples of
something where
our political system is just doing a
terrible job you know we have a party
that has been like
um bought out by climate change deniers
for years and years and years and has
like basically superstitious ideas about
you know climate and you know the
environment and things like that
um and then we have another party that's
pretty ineffective and often uh beholden
to corporations and
um you know there's not a lot of people
like The Lorax speaking up for the trees
but we're all going to be screwed
because of it
um and because of foolishness and greed
and an unwillingness to to do the things
that need to be done
um
so we'll see if we can you know manage
to deal with things I mean the smart
money for over two decades has been on
yes climate change is real and it's a
real problem the Rand Corporation our
military have been planning for you know
the crises that are going to come about
due to climate change insurance
companies they believe climate change is
real because they're going to start
charging more and more premiums for a
living you know along the coast or in
floodplains or in places that are going
to be hit by drought and stuff like that
so yeah Kenneth will a fully functional
AI coming online be about a greater
philosophy so we don't know that AI will
ever happen AI is a metaphor not a
reality
um everything that we've got so far is
not intelligence or you know machine
learning is not actually learning
um maybe we'll see something like that
happening
um I I have a hard time thinking that
it'll be able to under understand
philosophy particularly well certain
technical topics maybe yes but um I
don't even know that AI will be able to
handle Logistics particularly well you
know
uh Ethan
do you think Trump should be convicted
for violating the Espionage Act I mean
Trump should be convicted for a whole
ton of stuff I mean he's a terrible
person who's been defrauding the public
and contractors for decades
um nobody should be handling him with
kid gloves he should die in prison the
way that so many other people who have
done similar crimes have you know
uh Mark says vase this is Simone Ray
argues that when Christ said he came not
to uphold the law but to fulfill it he
was not this was not limited to Mosaic
law other religions could be read
through a Christian lens uh what do you
think of that
I think we've got to be careful reading
other religions through a Christian lens
what that Christian lens looks like so
that it doesn't wind up being one more
um sort of like
good intention missionary work that
effaces the other religion
um
and
I mean there is some interesting stuff
some discussions about this in not so
much in papal encyclicals but letters
you know and in in other
um theoretical discussions where people
are trying to
you know you could say syncretize or or
connect together different different um
Faith Traditions but
I'm not um super super
um
optimistic about about doing that kind
of stuff
um
all right uh
let's see here we're at time but all
um take a few more questions so Andre
has got a follow-up about Role Models
would you pick a role model based on
your character as a whole or based on
how they display certain virtues well
both of course you know uh and probably
some other stuff as well how well they
uh uh communicate you know how
consistent they are I mean I don't think
there would be a single Criterion that
you would use and there's also
availability you know who do you have
that you can look to as a role model
um how connected do you want to be with
them right
um Mario says uh do you think green
capitalism is possible or is it a
contradiction in itself I mean almost
nothing's a contradiction in itself when
you start getting down to it I mean this
would be something where you could so
easily just like look around for
companies that are claiming to be
engaged in sustainability or following
the triple bottom line or stuff like
that then ask yourself are they actually
uh still involved in capitalistic uh uh
you know structures and uh flows and
economies and stuff like that I mean the
answer I think is yes but it it you know
it's not as if there's as if capitalism
is just one single thing there's lots of
ways to do capitalism right
um
Austin any thoughts on Christopher
Hitchens totally overblown I don't think
that he was particular I think he's very
clever but I think he was kind of uh
kind of a dork you know I never found
him really great to to read or to listen
to myself but I guess a lot of people
like him
um
a meal are you optimistic or pessimistic
about Rehabilitation not either because
I that's too vague in general of a
question uh for me to be optimistic or
pessimistic about so so some people are
saying thanks for um the uh discussion
and the AMA I've got a
another thing I got to get to at two
o'clock but yeah good good questions got
to talk about some philosophy some
politics some music stuff a nice mix so
I think we'll we'll bring it to a close
here and um
say uh thanks to everybody for for
showing up uh uh and um you know we do
these every month
um so you know you can get in on those
um we've got a couple other things
coming up later this month we're doing
finally getting to the worlds of
speculative fiction and talking about
Philip K dick and Androids and humans
um we got a few other oh I'm talking at
stoicon X Midwest next Saturday
uh which you can find on my reason I O
calendar and also in my my Facebook uh
events
there's something else but I'm I'm not
remembering what it is so all right well
have a great evening those of you who
are much further east of of uh where I
am here in Milwaukee have a great
afternoon those of you here in the
Americas and if anybody's tuning in from
yet further west further east depending
on how you're doing it and it's the
middle of the night
um you know
get some sleep and I'll see you next
time